jeff howell of the athletic joining us
here on the rich eisen show how are you
jeff
doing well how are you i'm doing fine
will you do me a favor and ask bill why
he can't quit brian hoyer would you mind
doing that i'll give you five bucks
if that was that was sort of a surprise
because the way that they have
managed quarterback reps in training
camps off season
whatever i mean it's hard to get three
quarterbacks enough reps
and adding a fourth to the mix like you
know he's gonna be a quality mentor to a
guy like
mac jones not the cam newton wouldn't be
right but you know just
a extra set of eyes for somebody like
mac jones as he's trying to learn the
process
i i guess there's there's unquestionably
some value there but it still
i can't say i wasn't surprised when they
signed it well i read your piece again
you you cover the patriots for the
athletic you came up with 56
different things to watch for as the
media's led in on the first
time uh this spring for for practice for
the patriots and i guess you you
suggested that hoyer
would remove the mentoring a little bit
off of cam's plate
for mac jones like that might be one way
for for warrior to essentially be added
to the mix here how
how do you see the patriot quarterback
scenario
playing out for this year i still
expect just because of the way belichick
has kind of gotten out in front of this
starting the night they drafted mack
jones i expect cam newton to be the
starter going into the season
and today cam let off every
quarter every period of practice in
terms of the four quarterbacks i mean he
was the number one guy
and just going back to last summer when
there was more of an open competition
with him
jared stidham and brian hoyer you know
they rotated that first rep of a lot of
these team drills at least while it was
still a competition
uh but the thing that surprised me most
was
matt jones was the number two guy for
the majority of practice
including every period after they split
off into team drills now this wasn't
a high intensity practice by any stretch
of the imagination
and the only real competitive period was
a seven on seven period
but i thought it was a point where
if i had to bet i would have thought mac
jones would have been third
probably fourth on the depth chart today
just for today
because the way that you know the
patriots open up three of these 10 otas
to the media
so you can do whatever you want behind
closed doors in the other seven
you could have matt jones be the number
two guy uh when the media is not looking
but i was thinking when the media was
looking
hey let's figure out a way to slow down
this hype train let's make sure that you
know there's
there's not too much pumping of the
tires here and they didn't do that
and mac jones was that number two guy
and he throws a good ball he had a good
seven out of seven period he had a
couple
uh check down completions and then his
best throw was actually a drop by
christian wilkerson uh but it was a nice
read in a soft spot of his own
just you know wilkerson a former
practice squad guy couldn't make the
catch
and you know newton was four or four in
that period he had a couple balls that
uh were completed because of some great
catches uh by a tight end and a receiver
there
but i mean i think you're probably
starting the season with matt jones as
the number two
house did him plays is going to dictate
how long they want to keep him i mean if
he
comes in and plays well enough and they
decide that hey you know what cam newton
might only be here for enough most
likely
will only be here for another year you
got to think about who's the backup
going to be in 2022
if statum shows you enough uh but
there's i mean i could
i could throw a hundred quarterback
scenarios at you now i don't i don't
want to bore you with all of them no but
here's the thing
here's the key one jeff is because we
have no
there is no playbook on bill handling a
first-round drafted quarterback that's
just there there's
zero playbook to that with with bledsoe
being the last one
who was drafted in new england and that
that predates belichick and then you
look at what he had
even in cleveland you can't even go
there you can't i mean like literally
when was the last last time bill
even had anything remotely close to this
or of his of his own
doing so there's no playbook here and
the question is
is is what does happen if newton starts
and things of that nature and
and we don't have the playbook on that
at all or
or any any any history so
so how does jones work in does he just
do it just because he's got to do it or
pull you know or does he think that with
the free agency frenzy
the patriots have a shot to win the
division super bowl this year
jeff that's the question i guess and i
think
you're looking at this defense i mean
this it's an overhaul
group they there's a lot there's a a lot
of reasons to think that this defense
could be the number one
scoring defense in the league for the
third time in the last six years i mean
they're loaded their front should be
ridiculous
uh as long as they keep their secondary
intact and you know we'll see what
happens with stefan gilmore in the
coming months but
they can win games defensively so they
just need some confident quarterback
play
going into this offseason there was at
a full admission the cam newton had to
be better he had to clean up some
accuracy such
uh issues he had to clean up some
mechanics uh his left foot continued to
get away from him
at times last season and that's why
there were a lot of throwing
inconsistencies
and but there was also a concession of
there wasn't a lot of help around him
so they're going to try to see over the
next few months if adding hunter henry
and johnny smith and nelson aguilar and
kendrick bourne
uh and even get beefing up the offensive
line with trump brown they're going to
see if that
is going to help cam newton and he's
going to have a few months here to prove
whether or not that's the case and
that's totally different from last year
when
you know there was basically they were
going in for a two-week tryout and it
was those three guys it was
more realistically between cam newton
and jared stidham cinema had
seven interceptions in the first four
practices and then injured his hip
and cam newton played well enough the
competition was over
and bank you had to prepare him for week
one because that was a sprint
right now i mean you've got almost a
full off-season workout program
you're gonna have three pre-season games
you're gonna have a full training camp
so they're gonna know they're gonna have
a much much better idea
by the time labor day comes around
whether or not cam newton can be a
better quarterback
than he was a year ago if as long as
that happens he's going to be the
starter now if it's close
then you got you got some more of a
dilemma i guess if you want to call it
uh and then you look at the first four
games the first four games are some
tough matchups
the the next five or six are a softer
spot in the schedule
so again if it's close i think you got a
minimum
of four starts for cam newton before
they have to think about whether or not
they go to matt jones
if jones is ever going to take over if
he doesn't start the seasons between
weeks six and eleven
uh and then the other part of that is
this offense
it's built to run it's built to win with
power but if you're talking about
throwing the ball
with the two tight ends the the
receivers that you added with agalor
and kendrick bourne with jacoby myers is
a slot receiver
i mean you're built to throw the ball
over the middle of the field you need
really good accuracy there and where
does mac jones thrive i mean he thrives
by throwing an acura ball that was on
display today
newton's accuracy issues continue to
plague him
deep into the summer and mac jones is
able to learn enough of the playbook and
clearly can throw an accurate ball over
the middle to allow those guys to make
plays
you know that's going to be the thing
that really is going to push newton the
most in my opinion how about that
so when you say jeff howell of the
athletic here on the rich asset show
when you say that newton's going to get
the first four games and then after that
maybe
mac jones territory you don't think uh
belichick will give jones his first
career start the night brady comes in on
sunday night football the whole country
champion
you don't think he's got that flare of
the dramatic yeah what do you think jeff
you know what i didn't i didn't expect
uh belichick to give matt jones the
number two reps today in front of the
media which is clearly you know big
spotlight all of us quality journalists
over there celebrating in the practice
field just
ready to pump everybody's ties but he
did so you know what
mac jones tom brady week four sunday
night football that's great
lfg to use the phrase from from back in
the day and i guess last one on this uh
is winovich no longer wearing 50
um where where'd that one come from for
for matt
what happened started this probably
about five years ago
when it was the first pick in the draft
takes fifty the second pick the patriots
make
six fifty one and it goes right on down
the line so
uh it's just his message to the rookies
that you have to earn your number
don't worry about what jersey number you
are worry about the more important
things you know another part of that is
there's no logos on anybody's helmet
rookie or otherwise
so it's just uh one of those things that
belichick has done
over the years uh you know there was a
point several years
before that when during otas nobody had
any jersey numbers which made covering
practice just a blast
well certainly certainly certainly when
gronk gave himself his own number
jeff you know hey that was out in san
diego and man that was
uh so uh jeff howell the athletic here
on the rich eisen show
julio jones talk to me what are you what
are you hearing right now
uh on this uh media portion practice
uh of uh the the thursday before the
the first of june where something like
this could actually go down what are you
hearing about julio jones is a patriot
being possible i believe there is some
interest but i don't
know right now if i had to make a bet
i'm not sure i would
put the patriots as the betting
favorites to get him i think
the falcons are gonna have to make some
i mean they're going to have to scale
back their offer or their asking price
and i get why they're asking for you
know the the moon and the stars right
now because
they're not going to trade them for
another week so you you owe it to
yourself to try to get that first round
pick
so the falcons are going to have to
lighten their demands and
i think julio they're probably going to
have to take on some julio jones
contract
so some things are really going to have
to happen for him to wind up in new
england now i i saw
uh there was a report today that there's
a first round pick on the table if
that's indeed the case
i i don't think the patriots are going
to be willing to match that but
i i believe there's interest i just
don't believe there's interest
right now at the falcons asking price so
we'll see who blinks first in the next
week
right i mean but is there's only one
team in the league where atlanta
even though the general manager was
different at the time could go back and
say look
you gave us a two for muhammad sanu
we're not taking a two for
for julio you know i mean like that that
is
that is a reasonable response to
somebody who says we're not giving you a
one for a 32 year old wide receiver it's
not just any wide receiver and i'd
imagine
you know the way that they upgraded and
the way that they do have the ability
what they did in free agency to take
advantage
of other teams cap problems with the cap
over the next
year already being announced having a
ceiling of 208 million bucks
i mean you you got to think maybe now's
the times ripe to do it just go and do
it
right go go get an alabama wide receiver
for your
alabama quarterback even though they're
from along with
the alabama defense right yes absolutely
i mean right he would be a great fit
because all those guys who can produce
over the middle that we're talking about
earlier
now you have a i mean one of the games
best outside threats
i mean that would do a ton to really
balance your passing
in the offense and not just for this
season i mean you're talking about mac
jones
taking over i think at latest in 2022
adding a guy like julio jones would help
him beyond
so yeah i mean i i certainly see what
you're saying with the aggressive
approach and i understand
the the relation to the the muhammad s
new trade
but i think the the difference there is
if you're the patriots you're kind of
calling
the falcons bluff for right now and
you're gonna say hey you know whatever's
on the table let's say it is a second
round pick
right you know you're you're trying to
sit there and say
we know you're trading him i mean you
have the catfish you can't sign a single
one of your rookies
so you have to take whatever the best
offer is on the table
and the patriots are sitting there
probably saying uh
we believe this is the best uh offer
that you've got now who knows if there's
they also have to think that there's
another two
on the table from somebody else and then
when you look at this
roster and the way that it was
overhauled this offseason the falcons
have to sit there and say well that too
right now is
is possibly going to be you know the
50th pick the 55th pick depending on how
good they are
so what are the patriots going to do to
sweeten that you include a nikhil harry
you think you asked the falcons if they
were high on harry before the draft
maybe a change of scenery helps uh sway
them or do you include a fourth round
pick i mean there's
there are other pieces that you can add
i i just i don't think they'd be willing
to part with the first round
if they are i mean the aggressive
approach would fall in line with
everything else
that they've done in this offseason and
again i i think it'd be worth it based
on
how it would continue to help that
offense
so before i let you go um jeff hal the
athletic because again week four
sunday night football it's going to be
lit brady back in gillette i mean we
and we we m the hype you know began
yesterday
pretty much or the day that that
schedule finally came out
so in that spirit i asked this final
question of you
how much did the free agency period and
the possibility of looking at julio
jones
um and the way that they drafted um and
i understand they would never have
drafted the quarterback
uh that they did if they didn't maybe
still have brady
how much did brady winning in tampa
inform everything that we're seeing with
new england this year
jeff i think there's got to be a degree
to that
but the bigger factor here really i mean
the team just wasn't close to winning
enough games last year and
their offensive issues were paramount
i mean you look at the way the rams
defended them on national tv late in the
season i think you know
a week 14 or 15 something like that i
mean you
the rams basically said you are throwing
the ball in the
red zone and we know that and that was
it really magnified a lot of the issues
that they had there
and just looking at defensively i mean
they
their run defense was as bad as it's
ever been under belichick
their pass rush was the worst in terms
of sacks was the worst it's ever been
under belichick and because of a lack of
pass rush
you know they were a quarterbacks were
able to throw at their secondary without
a whole lot of fear
and you know they they needed to rebuild
that and the way that they did
i mean yeah of course they want to shut
down tom brady
i'm not i would never brush that that
aspect aside but the moves that they
made i mean adding
overhauling the defensive tackles
bringing matt udon
and kyle van noy to man the edges i mean
their their edge
defense against the run last year was
just it was awful
it's going to be so much better i mean
kyle that you got matt udon
who has the fifth most quarterback hits
in the league in the last
five years a reigning two-time pro
bowler kyle van noy was the patriots
best pass rusher in 2019
chase winovich was the p patriots best
pass rusher last year
joshua who uh i know you know rick
joshua is a name that the rest of the
league is going to get to know this year
he is going to be
really really good pass rusher he was
easily
their most explosive pass rusher last
year when he wasn't dealing with a
couple ankle injuries
and then he got ronnie perkins who was
one of the biggest deals in the draft i
mean you've got
five quality edge rushers and dante
hightower is expected back he had his
best pass rushing season
of his career in 2019. you know there's
six guys right there who can get after
the quarterback
and they're going to be able to do it
because the defensive tackles you know
their defensive tackles were just
so injury riddled last year that they're
just
their linebackers had no chance i mean
you had adrian phillips
as a natural safety playing one of your
inside linebacker spots for
almost 90 percent of the season so
they're uh
they had they had a lot of issues that
they had to clean up
regardless of of what tom brady and the
buccaneers did in that super bowl run
jeff thanks for the time really
appreciate it um let's uh let's connect
during training camp
appreciate it thanks a lot richard you
got to at jeff p howe on twitter i
follow him you should too he does his
stuff about the patriots and the
patriots are
as you can hear rebuilding hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here